should men
record themselves
to protect themselves from the women of
this modern generation
um i'll start going good um i i think
they should but
like
the part that i can't get around is do
do they tell the girl that they're
they're recording
because i i have a problem with
the idea of guys just like recording
girls and them not knowing
but at the same time
but are you going to be yourself
i know that's the other thing i can do
is recording i can see both sides that's
the hard part
because but i could see i could
definitely see like
recording like consent because like
girls are crazy nowadays they might say
something happened when it did it just
just talk well
oh i should just oh yeah you don't need
to put your hand up
okay
um
i was speaking to them yeah i was going
to basically say obviously it become
it's all within reason
because um and depends on serious it is
because what the flip side here is if if
it was the other way if it was have a
situation and a man was being violent
towards a woman
that question even wouldn't be asked
and
a a lot would have come of it if the man
was abusive or aggressive or
violent towards the partner towards the
woman
so again the question even would be oh i
thought we were talking about
like sex that's what i thought you meant
when you were recording oh so
if abuse oh my god yeah you should
record no but the thing is it's in both
instances i would say
that sex also can come into that and
also just interactions
generally whether it be like volatile or
whatever
i don't think anyone should record
anyone during sex without consent i
think it's wrong
um especially when you don't know what
the person is going to do with it i just
don't get that point
yeah why would you do that why would you
feel to do that um
good question i'll tell you why
have you guys heard of a book called how
to destroy a man
yes
so there's a book called how to destroy
a man you can find it on amazon and i'll
read the synopsis it says
want to destroy a man's reputation and
remove him from power
for misconduct this handbook by angela
confidential tells you how
in how to destroy a man
angela confidential empowers women with
a step-by-step guide for ruining in a
man's reputation and removing him from
positions of power
and in easy to understand terms the
handbook reveals and explains the
fundamental dynamics between allegations
the media and authority as they relate
to male misconduct in today's society it
also unveils and details practical
real-world methods for leveraging
allegations media and authorities to
dethrone a man so she's a mystery she's
a misandrist if we're gonna is that a
word
i'm just saying if there's a handbook
out there
on how to destroy a man shouldn't men
protect themselves i mean everything's
within reason isn't it so if you're a
reverse person that you feel that you
have to do that maybe then you shouldn't
be with that person
so
i mean it's a long
road to go through you know it's it's
that's why people say a lot of the time
but it's if you're seeing red flags
so if you're going to get to that
position i wouldn't even go down that
road but it's interesting that he's out
there because obviously some people
out there know about that without even
reading that book
well i mean did you hear about that
there was a college case in the u.s
um and i can't remember what school it
was but basically the girl had a i'm
gonna use the word grape allegation
um
against this guy and basically said he
like came on to her and the only reason
that
he
um
yeah the only reason he got out of this
was because there was a video of them at
the bar
and she was like literally pulling him
back to the dorm
and it and then when they got to the
dorm like there's video of her like
enthusiastically like making out with
him and all this stuff
and if they didn't have that video
footage
the guy probably would have gotten
kicked out of school
as i'm saying it's a harsh one isn't it
because
the reality is it's not always the case
but if it is the case it's
understandable
so so
i think that
um
based off of what you just said it made
me think that
men so your original question was should
they ask
no should they just record yes i think
for their own protection i think they
should record because in today's society
what the woman says
it rarely gets questioned
and so
in
in a lot of legal cases it's either
it's a woman's word against the man's
word and so they can say
in that situation there was no videos
she would have got away with it
in
johnny depp's situation if we never
would have those videos it may have went
the other way may have went the same way
but i think that
men should do it because of the way
society is it sucks that is that way
that
women not all the time obviously there's
some women that abuse the system some
women that don't but
there's just
women's words against men words so
yes this is in the chat there's a
student who's the student still got
kicked out even after he showed video
proof that the allegations were false oh
wow wow you like you wouldn't say
something crazy i just i just wanted to
say okay so
when it comes to women being believed
all the time i don't agree with this um
i'm a woman that was not believed i had
recordings
um
i had recordings of him saying he raped
me
making fun of it mocking it and um
i sent it i gave it to who i needed to
give it to and they still claimed it was
not enough evidence because it didn't
have his face in it
even though it was from his phone number
you could hear his voice you knew it was
him it was still deemed not enough so as
much as we say that
oh when a woman says it oh it's
automatically true
that's not the case
so but i think do you think that that's
because of who you are versus versus if
you're a celebrity or someone of status
or maybe
if you were white or other ethnic group
you might have been believed i think
that um
obviously this my case was to do with
coercive control and behavior and it's
really really hard to prove
so
what's something that i saw after
coercive controlling what does that mean
so it's basically controlling someone
physically emotionally sexually
emotionally
and financially
um
i feel like there's one more but i can't
remember it right now um
mentally yes mentally as well psychology
it's also psychologically if you if a
person can damage you psychologically to
that point then it is coercive
controlling behavior
and
something that really really pissed me
off
after the case was dismissed
i saw that katie price
had um
won a case of coercive control and
behavior towards her i don't know
ex-boyfriend husband whoever it was one
of her partners
and it really irritated me because it
was like it's only because it's her
and then a few months later maybe a
couple weeks later i heard a story about
how she was caught drink or drug driving
or some kind of nonsense so it just
didn't make sense just because she's a
celebrity
you will send her ex-partner to prison
or convict him of something but when
there's real people actually out here
doing this kind of [ __ ] excuse my
language um
we're not believed but
i don't i don't think it's like
necessarily that they don't believe you
but i just think in a court case it has
to be innocent until proven guilty 100
percent and i and it's very um tough to
convict someone of anything because of
that but that's that's the issue there
was so many different pieces when it
comes to
domestic abuse itself
you can't just get evidence
it's like you're saying men should
record themselves right i agree record
record record everybody should record
but when that camera goes on when that
recording goes on and they know it's
going on they are not going to behave in
the way that they work
which is why i'm asking the question but
i think i think jess's point when she's
talking about like women automatically
being believed um i think what she means
is like in the media when a girl comes
forward and says something happened
um especially a couple years ago like
people automatically just took the
woman's side and in this case like amber
heard got an op-ed
um but without any evidence
and to me that's like insane
yeah so i think that's that's basically
what i'm saying
what i'm sorry
i feel like for me the media doesn't it
doesn't matter and when i say the media
i'm saying like celebrities are going to
do whatever they do but when it comes to
real people
why is it that when it comes to
celebrities oh they're believed straight
away but then it's when it's real people
it's like oh it's not enough i don't
know
see i think that like women are actually
believed right away in real life too
like i think a girl can ruin a man's
reputation on a campus and immediately
people take her side
like regardless of if she's shown them
the evidence so i like i think if i if i
went to my team and i said something
happened to me and i said it was that
person on this team or something like
that like they would automatically
believe me because i'm because i'm a
woman
yeah i think and and i could ruin
someone's reputation so i know
celebrities may be like seem out of the
ordinary but the issue is that if this
happened to a man with power money and
influence how many men did this happen
to across the country